generell sind tötungsdelikte viel
seltener als die meisten menschen
glauben also töten ist dann aus noch ein
phänomen das kann man durchaus so sagen
am krebs diabetes ärztlichen
behandlungsfehlern zu sterben oder in
der badewanne auszurutschen ist weit
lebensgefährlicher oder weit
wahrscheinlicher als opfer eines
tötungsdeliktes zu werden dass kinder
das ist definiert als personen unter 14
tatverdächtig sind beim mord totschlag
oder tötung auf verlangen das sind 0,3
prozent das heißt man kann sagen das ist
ein ausnahme phänomen innerhalb des
ausnahme phänomens und wenn man dann
noch über mord spricht was ja mord
merkmale noch voraussetzt dass es noch
seltener denn meistens sind das eher
beziehungstaten streitsituationen dinge
die aus dem affekt passieren also
totschlag das heißt wenn kindermorden
ist eine ausnahme phänomen im ausnahme
phänomen im ausnahme phänomen hier muss
man aber präzise sein bei dem fall über
denen wir jetzt sprechen ist die person
über 14 as 14 lebensjahr vollendet und
das ist eine wichtige grenze warum weil
in der polizeilichen kriminalstatistik
sind kinder definiert als personen unter
14 von 14 bis 18 sind es dann
jugendliche von 18 bis 21 heranwachsende
und darüber dann erwachsen
das heißt 14 ist eine wichtige grenze
weil da genau in der statistik wenn man
so will eine neue schublade aufgemacht
wird
und 14 auch das alter der
strafmündigkeit das heißt das ist ganz
prinzipiell eine wichtige altersgrenze
das heißt hier sprechen wir nicht über
ein kind was ein tötungsdelikt geht
sondern über einen jugendlichen und das
passiert schon deutlich häufiger als bei
kindern aber auch jugendliche sind mit
fünf prozent eine verhältnismäßig kleine
gruppe innerhalb der personen die töten
ja wenn es gerade angesprochen oft sind
es dann beziehungsdramen auch in diesem
fall scheint es momentan nach den
aktuellen erkenntnissen so zu seiner
trotz muss man auch sagen wenn das im
affekt passiert ist hat er danach das
mädchen versucht zu verstecken mit
schutt bedeckt was bedeutet dieser
weitere schritt das ja sozusagen nicht
in dem moment erkannt hat was er gemacht
hat und versucht hat das irgendwie
wieder gut zu machen oder das sofort zu
melden sondern noch versucht hat seine
trat dann doch zu vertuschen
ich denke hat er kann was er gemacht hat
denn sonst hätte er die leiche nicht
verstecken müssen das heißt er hat schon
sehr genau erkannt was er getan hat ist
aber zu der entscheidung gekommen statt
zugestehen zu probieren das ganze zu
verdecken
wie ernst gemeint oder wie nachhaltig
aber diese anstrengungen waren ist
fraglich denn er hat schon sie wurde als
vermisst gemeldet wenn er hat schon der
polizei auch mitgeteilt dass sie sich
gerne dort aufhielt das hat man kann
schon schlussfolgern dass er wohl wollte
dass sie auch gefunden wird das heißt
dies war vielleicht ein verzweifelter
versuch zeit zu gewinnen zeit
aufzuschieben aber eigentlich kein
ernsthafter versuch oder ich denke nicht
dass er ernsthaft geglaubt hat damit
davonzukommen dass auch möglicherweise
gar nicht wollte trotzdem hat er zu dem
zeitpunkt erst mal noch nicht gestanden
oder sich gestellt sondern es ist auf
dieser art zu der aufklärung gekommen da
auch ihr bruder ihr handy über eine app
orten konnte oder ihren standort kannte
wurde sie so relativ schnell gefunden
aber da muss man natürlich auch sagen
töten ist für jeden menschen und selbst
für personen die durchaus
psychopathische züge haben eine
extremsituation für jemanden der keine
psychopathische züge also durchaus zu
empathie imstande ist wenn das ganze im
streit passiert der stein die vase was
auch immer in der nähe war schlag auf
den kopf sie fällt sie stürzt sie stirbt
ob das gewollt oder ungewollt war ob das
so geplant war
das steht alles noch in den sternen im
moment würde erstmal auch wegen
todschlags nicht wegen mordes ermittelt
und man kann es durchaus so
zusammenfassen wenn wir am ort sprechen
also wenn wenn niedrige beweggründe dort
sind oder aus heimtücke gehandelt wird
dann muss man nach der ursache in der
person suchen man muss also die frage
stellen was ist das für ein mensch der
so etwas kaltblütig tut bei totschlag
liegt die ursache oft er in der
situation als in der person kurt lewin
hat mal den schönen satz gesagt ein
psychologe verhalten ist gleich person
mal situationen das heißt jeder art von
verhalten die wir zeigen dass eigentlich
eine kombination aus zwei dingen unserer
persönlichkeit und der situation in der
wir uns gerade befinden und manchmal
liegt die ursache für kriminalität er in
der situation als in der person mit
anderen worten in extremsituationen kann
fast jeder vielleicht nicht zum mörder
aber mindestens zum totschläger werden
ja gewalt im elternhaus ist einer der
wahrscheinlich wichtigsten aspekte das
heißt man kann schon sagen dass gewalt
etwas ist was manchmal von generation zu
generation weitergegeben wird
glücklicherweise ist jetzt kinder zu
schlagen in der erziehung kein mittel
mehr was im durchschnitt der bevölkerung
angewendet wird aber es gibt natürlich
die familien wo es passiert und damit
bringt man kindern lediglich eine sache
bei nämlich dass gewalt ein adäquates
mittel ist um sich durchzusetzen dinge
durchzusetzen den eigenen willen
durchzusetzen und konflikte damit zu
regeln das ist das einzige was sie
dadurch lernen und das geben sie dann
durchaus auch wieder an ihre kinder
weiter und so weiter
das heißt eine gewisse gewaltspirale die
über die eltern an die kinder wenn man
so will weitergegeben wird und sich von
generation zu generation fortsetzt ist
leider etwas was man beobachtet also
kinder die gewalt erfahren haben neigen
selbst erzog gewalt aber und das will
ich auch ganz klar sagen es gibt viele
kinder mit gewalt erfahrungen die nicht
schwere körperverletzungen begehen oder
keine anderen menschen töten
es ist ein teil der erklärung aber auch
nicht die ganze erklärung mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bild schaut euch hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren